a part of that
is collecting the data which is kind of
something we've talked a little bit
about but
is there something you can say about how
we can like can collect
more and more data not just on the
one person level like for you to
understand
your like various markers but
to create huge data sets to understand
how we can detect
certain pathogens detect certain
properties characteristics of
whether it's aging or all the other ways
the human body can fail
it seems like with the with biology
there's a kind of
privacy concerns that well actually not
privacy concerns it's almost like
regulation
that kind of prevents like hospitals and
sharing data
you know i'm not sure exactly how to say
it but it seems like
when you look at autonomous vehicles
people are much more willing to share
data
when you look at human biology system
people are much less willing to share
data is there
a hopeful path forward where we can
share more and more data at a large
scale
that ultimately ends up helping us
understand the human body and then
treat problems with the human body so
we're right in the middle
we're living through what's going to be
seen as one of the biggest revolutions
in human health
through the gathering of data about our
bodies
and 20 years ago people didn't want to
go on social media they're worried about
it now
you have to if you're a kid that's for
sure uh
same with medical records these are
becoming all digitized and
and expanded ultimately we're going to
even if we don't want to have to be
monitored
you know there's going to be a cold case
that i bet two three years from now
someone's going to say
how come my father died from a heart
attack you had these biosensors 20 bucks
and you didn't use it
lawsuit right there and suddenly all
hospitals have to give you one of these
there'll be a reversal
like to where it's your fault if you
don't collect the data that's brilliant
that's and that's absolutely right i
mean that's
absolutely right that's the frustration
i feel when going to the doctor
is like you're it's almost negligent
to not collect the data because you're
making if there's something
really wrong with me and you're making
decisions based on very few tests
that's almost negligent when you have
the opportunity to collect a huge amount
more data
well like let me tell you something yeah
like the but
i've got this inside tracker data for
for myself over a decade
and you'd think my doctor would roll his
eyes at this oh he's gone to a consumer
company blah blah blah
i i had my first checkup in a year with
him through video conference
and he was running
blind he really didn't know what was
going on with me he asked the usual
things
how am i sleeping how am i eating these
kind of usual things
and i said well i've got new tests back
from inside tracker and he said
great i'd love to see them so i share
screen and we look at the graphs look at
the data
and he's loving it because he cannot
order these tests
willy-nilly so i said well let's order a
hba1c blood glucose levels because i'm
very interested in that that tracks with
longevity and he says well
i have no reason to order that do you
have a family history
no uh are you have any symptoms of
diabetes no well i can't order the test
i almost wanted to reach through the
computer and strangle him um
but instead you know i i pay a little
bit to get these tests done and then he
looks at them
so that's now the way consumer health is
going is that you can get better data
than your doctor can and but they like
you to do that
quick human question maybe you can
educate me
i've i think doctors sometimes have a
little bit of an ego
i understand that the doctor super
experienced a lot of things but
this is a fundamental question of human
variability
like i know a lot of specific details
about like
um i mean depends of course what we're
talking about but there's a i bring a
lot of knowledge
and if i have data with me then i have a
like
several orders of magnitude more
knowledge and
i think there's an aspect to where the
doctor has to
put their expert hat like
take it off and actually be a curious
open-minded person
and study and look at that data do you
think it's possible to sort of
change the culture of the medical system
to where the doctors are almost
as you said are excited to see the data
or that's already happening it's really
happening now
we've probably lost the last generation
um that they're no hopers but
so i teach at harvard medical school and
they're excited about this they're
excited about aging which is a new
aspect to medicine oh wow we can do
something about that
and then yeah all this data what do we
do with it there's still the traditional
pathology and all that stuff which they
need to know
but time will change their
their uh mindset i'm not worried about
that and like we were discussing this
isn't a question of if
it's just a matter of when and it's you
know i have a front row seat on all of
this
uh i had breakfast with with a ceo who
uh is making this happen just yesterday
i can tell you for sure that most people
have no idea that this revolution
is occurring and is happening so quickly
if you're running a hospital and you can
save two thousand dollars per
cardiac patient what are you gonna do
you have to use it otherwise
you know the hospital down the road's
gonna be beating you
and there there are large hospital
aggregations so there's ascension and
others
that just have to go this way
for budgetary reasons and right now the
u.s spends what is 17
of their gdp on healthcare
for let's say one of these buttons on my
chest costs 20 bucks it's rechargeable
and it can predict people's health and
save on antibiotics
prevent heart attacks how many billions
if not trillions of dollars
will that save over the next decade
yeah so when the public wakes up to this
they'll almost demand it
like this this should be this should be
accepted everywhere this is obvious it's
gonna save a lot of money it's gonna
improve the quality of life well and the
cfos of hospital
yeah groups will have to and insurance
companies are gonna
wanna get in on this so now that gets to
privacy right if
should an insurance company have access
to your data i would say
no but you could voluntarily show them
some of it if they give you a discount
and that's also being worked on right
now
i hope we do create kind of systems
where i can volunteer to share my data
and i can also
take the data back meaning like delete
the data request deletion of data
and then maybe policy creates rules to
where
you can share data you could delete the
data and
i think if i have the option to delete
all
my data that that a particular company
has then i'll share my data with
everyone
like i feel like uh if the if uh
because that gives me the tools to be a
consumer
an intelligent consumer of giving of uh
awarding my data to a company that
deserves it and taking it back when the
company is misbehaving
and in that way encourage as a consumer
in the capitalist system
encourage the companies that are doing
great work with that data
well yeah health care data security is
is number one uh on
on my mind uh inside tracker made sure
that that was true but
you know these buttons on your chest
there's very private stuff they can
probably tell
if you're having sex one night right so
this is not the kind of stuff you want
leaked
yeah so i don't know whether it's
blockchain or speak for yourself i want
this public
life i guess it depends on how you how
how you go but yeah
uh you know there there's a lot of stuff
you don't want out there and
this definitely has to be number one
because it you know it's one thing to
have your credit card
information stolen it's another thing
health records are permanently out there
you